[Música]
posturas cruzadas en la comunidad
internacional sobre el envío de
municiones de racimo a Ucrania Estados
Unidos confirmó que enviara este tipo de
artillería pero la medida genera
polémica y es rechazada por países como
Alemania que firmaron la convención
sobre dichas municiones que prohíbe su
uso por el hijo que representan para los
civiles
Pide a las autoridades de Guatemala
respetar los resultados de las
elecciones generales celebradas el
pasado 25 de junio la organización
asegura que los perdedores buscan
obtener resultados que no lograron en
las urnas
y se cumplen dos años del magnicidio de
Joel Moisés Quien fuera presidente de
Haití la investigación permanece
estancada y no se ha realizado ningún
juicio dos años después del magnicidio
el país continúa asumido en un sinnúmero
de crisis y la inseguridad ha ido en
aumento
Hola Bienvenidos a esta emisión
informativa de Franz 4 en español
dedicada a las principales noticias de
América soy Santiago aristea y
comenzamos con información vinculada a
la guerra en Ucrania y es que Estados
Unidos finalmente confirmó que enviará
municiones de racimo a quien a pesar del
riesgo humanitario que representan en el
año 2008 más de 100 países firmaron una
convención que prohíbe su uso pero
Estados Unidos Rusia y Ucrania no
estaban entre ellas la administración
aprobó este envío como parte de un nuevo
paquete de ayuda a kiev Aunque el
mandatario señaló que la decisión fue
difícil más detalles en el siguiente
informe
un arma controvertida y muy tímida que
será suministrada a Ucrania por Estados
Unidos es lo que confirmó este viernes
el asesor de seguridad nacional
estadounidense Jake Sullivan a pesar de
sus posibles efectos humanitarios
devastadores
reconocemos que las municiones en racimo
Crean un riesgo de daños a la población
civil debido a las municiones sin
detonar por eso Hemos aplazado la
decisión lo que se ha podido pero
también existe un riesgo masivo de daño
civil si las tropas y los tanques rusos
pasan por encima de las posiciones
ucranianas toman más territorio
ucraniano y subyugan a más civiles
porque Ucrania no tiene suficiente
artillería las bombas de racimo ya están
siendo utilizadas tanto por las fuerzas
rusas como por las fuerzas ucranianas en
la guerra son cohetes que dispersan
múltiples pequeños explosivos en un
amplio rayo y dejan tras de sí pequeñas
bombas sin explotar lo que supone una
amenaza para la población civil durante
años causando muertes y mutilaciones
Naciones Unidas han pedido a Rusia y
Ucrania que dejen de utilizar municiones
de racimo más de 100 países firmaron una
convención que prohíbe estas bombas
el secretario general apoya la
convención sobre municiones de racimo
que como saben se adoptó hace 15 años y
quiere que los países cumplan los
términos de esa convención y como
resultado por supuesto no quiere que se
sigan utilizando municiones de racimo en
el campo de batalla
[Aplausos]
Estados Unidos afirma que sólo enviará
municiones de Última Generación con un
menor porcentaje de bombas caídas es
decir que no explotan por su parte
Ucrania acogió con satisfacción la
decisión afirmando que necesita Estas
armas para derrotar a Rusia Estados
Unidos destruyó lo último de su arsenal
de armas químicas declarado aseguró el
presidente Joe biden y ponen así fin a
un esfuerzo de décadas para eliminar las
armas letales que se usaron por primera
vez a gran escala en la Primera Guerra
Mundial como parte de la convención de
armas químicas que fue ratificada por el
senado de Estados Unidos en 1997
Washington y otros signatarios deben
destruir sus reservas de armas químicas
antes del 30 de septiembre de 2023
y las autoridades de Guatemala deben
respetar los resultados de las
elecciones celebradas el 25 de junio
estos señalaron desde human right watch
y desde la oficina en Washington para
asuntos latinoamericanos wola y
advirtieron además que los gobiernos
interesados deben instalar al gobierno y
a otras autoridades a garantizar los
valores democráticos Y respetar la
voluntad de los guatemaltecos expresada
en las urnas en France 24 dialogamos con
Ana María Méndez dardón directora para
Centroamérica en wola sobre la polémica
revisión de votos que ordenó la corte de
constitucionalidad tras la denuncia por
irregularidades que presentaron nueve
partidos políticos
es sumamente preocupante lo que ocurre
hoy día en Guatemala
porque una narrativa de fraude
recordemos que cuando es sin fundamento
es una amenaza para la democracia pero
más grave Aún es la judicialización de
un proceso sin reconocer la voluntad
popular y
con ellos se puede Más bien constituir
una violación a la democracia misma
dejar un proceso electoral en el Limbo
es muy grave y creo que lo más dañino
para un proceso electoral es la
incertidumbre
lo que hay detrás pues históricamente
Guatemala ha sido gobernada por grupos
de poder que han sido vinculados a la
corrupción y al crimen organizado y por
primera vez mucho tiempo
un candidato social demócrata logra
incluirse en un segundo lugar para
correr en una segunda vuelta electoral
se cumplieron dos años del magnicidio de
hecho Quien fuera presidente de Haití el
fallecido mandatario perdió la vida
luego de una Santa su residencia privada
a manos de un grupo de mercenarios en el
país caribeño todavía no se celebró un
juicio por este caso y la investigación
ya pasó por cinco jueces y permanece sin
avances el informe es de Juan pupiales
un crimen que impactó al mundo 12 fueron
los tiros que recibió giovenel Moisés en
su propia residencia el 7 de julio de
2021 su muerte fue recordada este
viernes dos años después por parte del
Primer Ministro Ariel Angie quien
manifestó el que es un sentimiento
latente este magnicidio aún no se ha
resuelto
para el gobierno es importante que echó
en el Moisés encuentre justicia estoy
haciendo todo en mi poder para ayudar al
sistema judicial a ir hacia adelante
dentro de Haití el caso parece casi
estancado no se ha convocado a una
juicio y ya son cinco los jueces que han
asumido la investigación uno de ellos
renunció después de que su asistente
muriera en condiciones confusas más de
40 sospechosos permanecen en una cárcel
de Haití Incluyendo a 18 antiguos
soldados de Colombia acusados del crimen
para Martín La viuda de Moisés la
solución pasa por un tribunal fuera de
su país
ante el bloqueo institucional de los
asesinos en el poder hace falta un
tribunal especial internacional
en Estados Unidos se han producido once
arrestos por este magnicidio y uno de
ellos ya fue procesado para la fiscalía
de Florida detrás de la muerte de maíz
hay un gran complot internacional para
contratar a mercenarios y acabar con su
vida para luego beneficiarse de
cuantiosos contratos de la
Administración venidera avanzamos con
más noticias el ministro de economía de
Argentina Sergio massa anunció el
viernes que se levantó la huelga de
transporte que afectó durante toda la
jornada al área metropolitana de Buenos
Aires y a seis provincias del país la
medida tomada por la unión transviarios
automotor Utah tiene su raíz en la
denuncia contra las empresas que no
cumplen con el pago del aumento salarial
acordado sobre estas tensiones nos
reportaba desde Buenos Aires nuestro
corresponsal natalio cosoy básicamente
las empresas reciben un porcentaje muy
importante de sus gastos en forma de
subsidios del Estado las empresas dicen
que el estado no les dio la parte
correspondiente a ese pago que tenían
que hacer por ese último aumento
salarial recordemos que con la inflación
que hay en Argentina altísima inflación
más de 100 % anual los aumentos
salariales son bastante cotidianos y se
suceden muy rápidamente el gobierno por
el contrario dijo que sí le había girado
a las empresas el dinero necesario para
hacer ese pago la conclusión de eso y de
Esa diferencia Y de esa disputa fue que
los trabajadores decidieron cortar el
servicio desde la medianoche de este día
viernes hasta esta medianoche por suerte
para todas estas personas que tienen que
trasladarse en esta ciudad especialmente
y sus alrededores donde se concentran la
población muy importante una parte muy
importante de la población del país eso
se resolvió al menos temporalmente por
ahora y tal vez pueden ver detrás mío en
esta Avenida circular algún que es como
llamamos aquí a los buses aunque no con
la frecuencia habitual para un viernes a
la noche que es lo que se esperaría se
ve que de a poco se está restableciendo
el servicio y expertos sigue en
monitoreando la actividad de volcán
ubinas en Perú luego de haberse
registrado expulsiones de ceniza y gas
en los últimos días científicos del
instituto geofísico del país viajaron a
la zona y se ubicaron en la falda del
volcán para vigilar su actividad el
gobierno peruano decretó el estado de
emergencia por 60 días en las
poblaciones cercanas y efectivos del
ejército fueron desplegados para ayudar
ante una eventual evacuación al menos
dos mil personas estarían en riesgo
es todo por el momento ustedes pueden
ampliar estas noticias y conocer muchas
más en transmitir 4.com sigan junto a
nosotros
[Música]